hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapters 24 and 25 of his work on
friendship Marcus Tullius Cicero
broaches a topic that some of us might
not want to think about but he thinks is
absolutely important if we're going to
understand friendship properly and that
is criticizing our friends and also we
should think about this as applying to
ourselves not just as the critique er
the person who's giving the criticism
but how we should understand and
approach our friends criticizing us
because we do have a tendency like
everybody else to take offense at being
criticized especially by those who we
think ought to be supporting us backing
us saying good things about this is a
common human dynamic and unless somebody
is absolutely perfect and even Scipio
himself the great friend of Laelius he
says is superior to him it's not a
perfect human being and would expect to
have some admonition criticism however
we want to talk about it in this case
the translation is often rebuking which
is another nice term unless we're
perfect people we're gonna screw up and
we often do need our friends to be quite
frank with us very forthcoming and say
man you're messing this up you you have
to take care of this thing over here
you're kind of a jerk
maybe you should fix this personality
trait that you've got going on over here
that's something that if we were
correctly aligned if we were thinking
straight we would recognize as a good
thing not as simply an attack on us so
Cicero begins talking about this in 24
and he says that varied and complex are
the experience as a friendship they
offer many causes for suspicion and
offense which is why sometimes to ignore
sometimes to make light up and sometimes
to endure but he says there's one cause
of offense in friendship which must be
encountered in order
that both the usefulness and loyalty of
friendship may be preserved for friends
frequently he doesn't just say every
once in a while
frequently must not only be advised and
the word here for advise Mon nd is also
warned the friends not to don't need to
have the positive things set out to them
how this is going to be a great thing
that you can plan to do they also need
some some warning but they also have to
be as he's saying rebuked or criticized
we have to say negative things to our
friends about their own actions choices
motivations character at some points and
this is going to be very important so he
says that both advice and rebuke you
have to be taken in in a certain way if
we don't do this we're actually letting
our friends down and that's that's not a
good thing so let's let's talk about
some of the things that he's saying here
Before we jump into the how to do it he
says that this preserves usefulness
utility toss and loyalty or fidelity
fides within the friendship so there
there's two different things going on
here
it is useful for us to hear criticism of
ourselves when that criticism is on
point because it allows us to avoid
screwing things up worse and it helps us
to perhaps either recognize that there's
a problem that needs to be attended to
or to have the resolve of finally
dealing with it when our friends say man
you're kind of a jerk when you do this
or that you know you get stressed out or
you drink or you had you encounter some
sort of setback you turned into a
complete jerk maybe we already know that
but we need our friends to say man
you're screwing up in order for us to
take it seriously it's also part of
loyalty and this is where a lot of
people get mixed up they think that if a
friend is loyal they're not gonna point
out your flaws they're gonna have your
back all the time they'll never
criticize you
Cicero is saying that's a mistaken view
of friendship loyalty oftentimes means
doing the difficult work of calling
people out on the things that that
they're doing that aren't right now he
also says that it should be received in
a friendly way a meet gay right so
that's important you know we taking
criticism is often a difficult thing for
people to do but he says that should be
received in a friendly way when goodwill
is demonstrably there and been a
volunteer or goodwill is something that
is absolutely central to friendship it's
one of its main features now here he
doesn't actually say been a volunteer
it's been Evolis and at an adverb but
it's the same word essentially so with
goodwill now Cicero is going to stress
over and over again he's going to use
this word truth Veritas right as being
absolutely necessary for a friendship it
gets translated sometimes as sincerity
or in other ways but it's always truth
that he's talking about here truth is
needed for friendship and he says what a
troublesome thing truth is if it is
indeed the source of hate which poisons
friendship and then he says but much
more poisonous and troublesome is
something that we're translating here as
complacence in in the particular
translation I'm looking at here in the
Latin it's obsequious and we get this
nice English word from that obsequious
right obsequious miss is the
characteristic when somebody is
obsequious they are you know sort of
going along to get along I many of you
have probably heard that expression
there are people pleasers is another way
of putting it in our contemporary
parlance these are the people who won't
tell you the truth about things these
are the people who will cover up your
own screw-ups and won't tell you to your
face that you've been making mistakes
and then the mistakes will appear and
you'll be you know justifiably
a lot of people actually want people to
behave that way Cicero says that this is
actually a terrible idea why because it
shows indulgence to the screw-ups the
sins the flaws of a friend and allows
them to be carried away so it's
important to confront people that's
another term that we use to to confront
our friends and Cicero says we have to
be careful in doing this we we need to
approach criticizing friends in the
right way one thing he says is that we
need to use reason and care or diligence
the the term there is actually diligent
iya right so we need to think through
how we're going to criticize people we
shouldn't just fire things off-the-cuff
we should approach things in a careful
well planned out prudent way and that
also means we should point out from a
Ciceronian point of view that there's
going to be kind of a do measure to it
you don't just blast your friend in in
all sorts of ways about everything that
they're doing wrong you deal with things
in proportion you don't blow them as we
say out of proportion and treat I don't
know not not wearing you know the right
shoes or something to an event as if
it's like poisoning the punch bowl or
anything along those those sorts of
lines right so he also tells us we need
to be careful in our tone and this would
also I imagine extent to word choice he
tells us to avoid harshness acad toss in
latin it's the word that we get it's a
taste word meaning the things that you
know are kind of tough on our tongue so
imagine like taking a spoonful of
mustard and or you know that was it
could be also something like sriracha
sauce and just ladling it on your tongue
that's a carrot to us right you don't
want to do that sort of thing or
drinking vinegar right
that's not good don't do that with your
words don't say things in a mean way to
your friend you can tell them that
they're screwing up without rubbing
their nose in it
and avoid going even further and
engaging in insults in in Latin
contumelia right we get a word from that
that nobody uses these days which is
sort of a cognate but you know insult is
probably good enough don't say things to
your friends when you're criticizing
them they are going over the top you
don't have to stress to them just how
much they've screwed up it's enough to
to show them that there's a mistake
there and you'll more easily get them to
take it seriously Cicero says we also
have to avoid the other extreme and he
gives a lot of just you know discussions
and synonyms for this we have to avoid
flattery and he says that we have a
number of different words for this that
get translated he says there's nothing
to be considered a greater bane of
friendship than fawning cajole arre or
flattery forgive it as many names as you
choose it deserves to be branded as a
vice peculiar to fickle and false
hearted men who say everything with a
view it's a pleasure and nothing with a
view to truth right isn't that a
interesting phrase there why do people
engage in flattery they don't have guts
they can't actually stand the truth and
so they give other people things that
are going to sound good again we can
talk in terms of being a people pleaser
or going along to get along right
putting a the best face on it well if
it's a false face it's not the best face
we need to be honest with each other he
also talks about hip whats translated
here is hypocrisy being fake being phony
works just fine for this term simulator
we get the word simulation from this
when you're being a hypocrite literally
you're being an actor the people who put
the masks on on the stage and there's
all different ways in which we simulate
or dis simulate
things that we don't actually think or
feel so somebody comes along and says
hey give me my performance review we
want to be honest and saying well you're
doing great in these areas but man you
need to work on your delivery or you
probably should start organizing your
calendar because you keep missing
appointments and and that's not good for
for clients being fake is the opposite
of that now the thing that that is is
problematic here that Cicero talks about
is a common human dynamic and this is a
fault that I know I myself sometimes
suffer from and many people listening to
this probably suffer from as well and it
was similar issue and Cicero's time this
is probably part of human nature and
many people talk about this
Cicero focuses on people who are upset
with being criticized and are not upset
over the fault that's being criticized
instead they get upset with the fact
that that fault is being pointed out and
you could say well really they are upset
about the fault deep inside of them and
that's why they're so sensitive about it
but Cicero thinks that there is a kind
of blindness going on here
and he actually talks about a person
like this having a soul that's or a
personality that in some way is not a
unity it's not integrated it's at war
with itself he says that this is going
to stand in the way of friendship since
the effect of friendship is to make as
it were one soul out of many how will
that be possible if not even in one man
taken by himself there will be a soul
always one in the same but fickle
changeable and manifold multiplex right
so insofar as we're able to take
criticism we're able to become better
people and we're able to become better
friends and this is one of those things
that is unfortunately an integral part
of genuine friendship being able to give
criticism and take criticism in the
right
ways that's going to cement the bonds of
a friendship over time not being able to
do so is going to produce a a lack of
friendship and people are really badly
off he says when they are you know in
this case he brings up a saying of Cato
some men are better served by their
bitter tongue enemies but then by their
sweet smiling friends because the former
often tell the truth
the latter never we don't want to be in
that case we want to be able to accept
criticism and understand we might want
to project this this notion of goodwill
being there sometimes we have to remind
ourselves of that that real friends are
not criticizing us just to be jerks
themselves or to put us down or to have
power over us or any of these other
things to humiliate and embarrass us
for whatever kicks they get out of that
they're doing it because it's good for
us and so we can adopt that perspective
for ourselves and we can try to promote
that perspective for our friends
you